every once do you watch up with Collider
and I am here with someone named Vince
nice to see ya how you doing today today
thank you so much for coming in always
great to see you I appreciate it and
what I find fascinating you're here
promoting fighting with my family which
is the only film that you've probably
worked with the director taller than you
that's right it's Stephen Merchant itas
director tallest actor in the world so
it is a different perspective for me to
be around him but he's a he's an
enormous ly tall gentleman yes yes I
want to start by saying how much I
enjoyed the movie sincerely it tells us
really positive message as well as just
being an authentic movie about you know
this family talked a little bit about
are you a fan of wrestling I was growing
up I really enjoyed it I thought there
was such cool stuff in it and then as I
have gotten older I kind of lost touch
with it and I wasn't as familiar with
modern rustling I saw the documentary
and I thought that was so unique about
it was you know you have this young
girls dream which is such a unique world
that we haven't seen to go into
something like wrestling but it's like
you know almost mythological in that
it's a world across the ocean and
somewhere totally foreign and what I
found most interesting that I hadn't
seen is this the weight of almost like
you're living out your parents dreams
like you inherited these goals from your
family and so here you are not just for
yourself but ultimately like a family
legacy that was like fulfilling a
promise so I find it very moving that
way and then the wrestling aspect of it
getting into it and learning about it I
just had an appreciation for the
athleticism in modern wrestling the
flips and all the different stuff that
they do I mean it's it's odd to say but
the the people that go into it with the
passion they have it's not like there's
a long career opportunity there's not a
huge financial opportunity I mean a very
few people can make a living at it and
yet it's so challenging and so brutal on
your body that I just was amazed to see
the commitment that you would have with
all these young girls and and young guys
entering that world I think that a lot
of people I think a lot of people don't
give the credit that wrestling I'm not
someone who watches wrestling however I
have a tremendous amount of respect for
the athleticism that it takes to do this
because you do bring up the point that
it's it's like it beats your body up but
then it's also cool like you hear
how like Rick Rubin with Def Jam took a
lot of the wrestling selling points of
creating heroes and villains or heels
and kind of used that in the promotion
of those artists right there's there's
just there's a perminov that culture in
sort of marketing and advertising that's
been you know kind of taken from for a
lot of different industries completely
talk a little bit about did Steven make
you audition or was one of these things
where he said come over let's just have
a drink or a meeting yeah they said they
just got a call to do it we had talked I
heard about it a while and then they
came to me and asked me to do it was
kind of short notice the thing came
together fairly quickly so I just kind
of crammed then and went down locally in
Los Angeles to some places and talked to
some of those guys and most of them are
pretty banged up you know a lot of them
were ex wrestlers who were coaching
nowadays and teaching it so a lot of
them were kind of kind of uh banged up
and yeah then I kind of jumped in and
had a blast with Steven he's terrific uh
talk a little bit about memorable
moments from filming you have scenes
with you have some great scenes with a
lot of people in the film talk a little
bit like a day or two you'll always
remember well we went to Wrestlemania
why it was going on and I have not been
to a wrestling match live prior to this
and it was just it was such a special
you know a spectacular event I mean
there were so many people was in Los
Angeles so you had I think Rick Rubin
was there you had just so many different
people there the writer of Braveheart
was there Randall Wallace who I know I
was just amazed at the audience that the
the event drew and just the pageantry
you know just the pageantry of how they
kind of throw it was kind of awesome and
I brought my kids and my son came home
like really excited he was at all of
four years old the time and he threw a
chair across the room because he was
watching these kind of matches so it was
just it was really interesting to see
them do it you're like um it's not
really they were telling me earlier that
the first week of filming they had to
film the WrestleMania thing which is
it's crazy because you generally want to
build you want to get to know your
character a little bit before you're
performing in front of I don't know
20,000 people mm-hmm mm-hmm I didn't
have that pressure like like like the
actors did who were performing that you
know they were just so prepared I think
they had gone to
and done some physical training prior to
that but yeah I mean you have a the
oddity of doing a live performance in
front of a lot of people with high
expectations and you're you know you're
being woven in simultaneously with
professionals who perform this stuff
live so I'm sure there was a lot of
anxiety as far as pulling off the moves
in a way that was believable completely
what's the you've done obviously you had
a great career and I'm curious what is
the why don't you been asked to do
really early in a shoot if you remember
that you're like I cannot believe I have
to do this in the first week well love
scenes come to mind that's always you
know you don't know someone and it's
just the scheduling work so you kind of
jump into that so and sometimes it's
nice if you have like bigger performance
demanding pieces to kind of get it out
of the way early versus having it kind
of bloom so yeah I can think of those
those kind of things popped in my mind
have you seen the finished film I have
yeah what was your reaction the first
time I thought it was really terrific I
love Florence in it she's terrific and
you really root for them and the whole
family dynamic is great you know it's so
interesting to see the common threads of
parents this kind of working-class
family wanting better for their children
and the children kind of inheriting this
family legacy but just the world's
interesting the journey of it I think
it's always one of the fun things and
watching films it's nice to be
entertained and then it's on top of that
if you can get a little bit of an
education and in this case you're just
learning about a world so you're picking
up sort of how this thing goes down and
it becomes interesting because we're not
overexposed to it and then it's
ultimately I think a story that's been
told it's sort of the hero's journey
that you have sort of this this girl
with her doubts and fears and
the facing of those and then ultimately
the resurrection of her into this sort
of you know realized dream I'm a big fan
of Stephen I think he's really talented
both in front of the camera and behind
the camera what was it like working with
him and because as an actor I'm curious
what kind of notes he gives on set he
was terrific he was very collaborative
you know the script was still kind of
going through stuff as we were working
so we talked a lot about you know just
the wrestling how to how to incorporate
the information in a way that doesn't
feel too expository and kind of what
journey is so there was lots of really
good conversations and and playing
around with stuff as far as finding the
best ways to try to you know get across
the points and keep it on story or keep
it fun we are here at Sundance yes I'm
very curious how many have you been here
I have not you know I told this earlier
but we made the movie swingers and
Sundance was a destination we did not
get into Sundance and then the first
movie that John directed to the first
movie I produced was called made and
that did not get into Sundance so we are
here now with this with fighting with my
family and I don't know if I had come
one time younger or not but yeah I do
not have a long a long history with the
festival I was gonna say it's it's
pretty shocking I mean also the the
Dwayne Johnson is coming in for this so
he has a Sundance movie as well yeah
yeah that's right it's crazy that's
right you look at the movies that he
does right now and you're like none of
these are going to Sundance right here
we are it's crazy
what is it like for you though you're
what we call tall yes and there's a lot
of people here that like seeing
celebrities yes you can't really blend
in as far as I can tell well I've been
able to kind of put this kind of
terrific ski coat with this hood and I
can kind of dip it if I need to move
quickly through places but people here
are really they seem to be film
enthusiasts and people are very friendly
so I enjoyed saying hi to people on the
street people here or kind of seemed
very nice so it's been been pretty easy
with the with the Sundance being so many
movies are world premiering here as a
film fan which I know you love movies do
you try to come in a few days early or
stay a day late to just like see movies
or is your schedule not allowing well
you know that's the oddity right that
the original fun of a Film Festival
which used to be more this way
was that you would get a chance to see
other people's work and you would get a
chance to see people sometimes and that
is not as common anymore so much of the
festivals now are people promoting and
talking about their films that your your
schedules pretty filled up with talking
about your movie so unfortunately you
don't get a chance to check out stuff
but I've heard of some things you were
saying a movie that you liked earlier
yet like late night late night you liked
yeah that was great - anything else that
you've seen that kind of press
Shia LaBeouf was great in honey boy that
was good
also wrote yeah I saw blinded by the
light last night which was great if you
have springsteen you're gonna love it
that's cool
this has been a good year that's great
you know everyone who's been coming in
we've been doing something called get to
know your Sundance attendee okay and I
swear these a harmless questions doesn't
happy to be to be harmed or unarmed yeah
here we go
uh what TV show would you love to guest
star on boy gosh I'm doing one recently
I'm about to do one that I'm kind of
excited about that I think will be fun
can you can you know if I can't get in
trouble but I'm about to do one a couple
of things so I can't say but right but
you'll see got it do you have a favorite
sci-fi or fantasy film that's a great
question a favorite one gosh like the
top of my head just because it came and
I always preface this by saying it might
be my favorite in this moment but
allowing that that could change that I
could have another force plant of the
Apes came to mind I remember really
being impacted by that movie as a kid
with the whole you know twists and turns
and realization ultimately that there
was a Statue of Liberty great writer
obviously Rod Serling from Twilight Zone
did that but that was a terrific film do
you have your shirt what is yours oh man
the problem with that and if we happen
to say one now at the top your head
because I could go on I still I still I
mean listen like I could mention 2001 I
mention all of these things but I I
really I've watched the Lord of the
Rings trilogy the extended editions way
too many times that would came to go
number one minute and I really think
that Peter Jackson and what they did
with that trilogy is just so amazing and
it was just for me but I mean did you
read the books younger no I actually
have not read the books and I haven't
watched read The Game of Thrones books
and but I love the show right right but
I mean look the and as you know as a
film fan the you it's it's so difficult
because do you talk about a movie that
is the precursor that built that
everyone built on like a 2001 you know
right do you that's the thing that
happens is one is built on the other
like folk music or anything so when you
pay homage to one you're doing it too
all right for sure um do you have a
favorite superhero movie that's a good
question do I have a favorite superhero
movie you know I kind of checked out
watching them as recently and I guess
the stuff that would have impact
impacted me maybe was the stuff that you
would see younger in the dawn or
Superman
I'm trying to think of a favorite and
I'm sort of it's hard because you have
different ones that you like maybe I'll
go
maybe I'll go with the first Ironman
because you know obviously Favreau and
Bill and Peter Bowie's he produced that
but I also thought it was inventive I
hadn't seen a superhero movie done that
way you know in a way it kind of became
the pilot for a lot of the Marvel movies
where you have a balance of humor and
stuff in it so maybe I'll go with that
one I think that John and everyone
involved in that movie does not get
enough credit for what that movie did
because a lot of people don't realize
I'm if I'm not mistaken Marvel took out
like a five hundred million dollar loan
to make three movies and if they didn't
work they were gonna lose all the
characters my understanding was that
when they made that film that you know
no one really knew what would happen it
was sort of a lesser-known of the Marvel
titles at the time it you know wasn't
spider-man or something that was as well
known and so there was some risk
involved and again I think they totally
did something a little bit different you
know they brought some comedy and
different tone to it and as you know
with with watching movies tone is
everything if you establish a tone it's
a tricky thing right you got to stay
within that so I'll go with that do you
collect anything I'm not a real big
collector I do have a collection of some
sports stuff just because I produce a
interview show with with athletes and so
I get some signed stuff as it goes but
I'm not I'm not a big collector younger
I was more of a collector sure
do you play Dungeons & Dragons on those
kind of games so I used to get those
conjurer lead things sure you know
there's a huge popularity of Dungeons
and Dragons again now a lot of people
play what's fascinating about that is it
was sort of the first perspective of the
single player you know now you see a lot
of the video games and stuff that people
play but that was the first game that I
remember sort of introducing a world
where you were a character an error and
sort of navigating it or an avatar if
you will so he was like before that and
I always found those guys interesting
Gary Gygax
and that crowd you scottson right you
find them interesting you drop the name
that story got that story is so but
without them in that role-playing game
you probably wouldn't have whether it's
Grand Theft Auto or any of these things
that have come into such popular I
completely agree do you remember your
first movie or TV show crush
gosh my first movie or TV show crush
know if it was a crush but I remember
seeing Paper Moon as a kid and really
being taken by thinking she was
interesting Tatum O'Neal loving that
character in that film I was very young
I remember thinking like she's really
cool like I don't know what this means
but it means something yeah yeah
do you own any movie or TV show props do
I own any I have stuff probably from
films but I don't I don't really check
on it so I can't say and I'm not a I
don't purchase things so nothing comes
to mind but I know I have probably
something somewhere sure
background photo on your phone it's just
the thing it comes with unfortunately I
am too analogue oh no no I have a
picture of my daughter my daughter from
when she was a bit one of the pictures
from when she was I think a year old
it's me holding her I just you know I
never owned a cell phone until I was
married and the first Father's Day my
wife gave it to me because I never owned
one and then I remember when I first
started taking pictures it was with my
my daughter so I have a pipe my phone
saver is her was your own on my computer
it's still like the mountain I don't
know where they took that shot by the
way well you know everyone's likes the
same mountain with the lake there's no
one lives there it's like an
uninterrupted nature I don't know where
it is
what was your aversion to getting the
phone or was it just you just had no
interest you know what it was is I
always felt like I didn't love being
able to be reached at any time you know
I didn't want that I was kind of and so
I always felt like well Gavi answer
machine always work like this isn't
broken like someone leaves a message and
at some point you check it and you get
back to them the whole phone thing to me
felt like I'm gonna carry a phone you
know so funny so I just never did it and
then you know obviously now that I do it
like everybody else you do kind of rely
on it more completely I think that even
if you don't I think there's an
addiction to social media but I do think
that having a phone for emergencies is
really important no question social
media so if it's good I guess you know
but there's also just websites or news
or you're able to get information so
quickly so I like that or if you're
curious about something the ability to
look something up and read about it is
nice to have but then you can spend a
lot of time you'd know down a FOXO as
they say and deep dive completely what
TV show have you watched all the way
through more than
once well the stuff for me that I would
go back to is still like Sanford and Son
which was not obviously you know it was
sort of one offs but I probably watch
that show more than any other show sure
these are it's um this or that
okay so Star Wars or Star Trek Star Wars
game of thrones or Breaking Bad Game of
Thrones Han Solo or Indiana Jones Han
Solo
you are very decisive yes like there's a
lot I'm just trying to go with what's
comes to the first of my Oh cuz I some
people will sit there and literally like
they have like the look of you know
they're going to the bathroom sure
you're just challenging but you know
again I always say like I just go with
that guy could feel differently at a
different times because we're talking
about some some pretty fun this or that
do you remember what as a kid or when
you were younger what got you interested
in the entertainment industry was it
like a performance was it a movie was
there something that said oh my god I
want to do that you know looking back if
I can connect to it I had I remember my
my dad really liked movies my mom and I
would watch old movies and they kind of
let me watch stuff I was the youngest so
I would see stuff that was not
necessarily age-appropriate both in the
theater and as well at home and I really
was just drawn to the storytelling and
obviously the dynamics of the characters
and then my family did something
interesting where they would reenact a
scene might like just you know this is
before but what are the family things we
would do is say okay everyone's gonna
audition for the 10-man like just in the
living room so you get up and do it then
someone else gets up and do it I always
found that to be fun it was kind of like
just playing games but we would sort of
act out you know characters from a
Western and everyone would kind of take
their turn at it so it was a way to kind
of laugh with your family and so I
enjoyed that and so movies and going to
was very fortunate my my family took me
to a lot of plays and stuff younger so I
was always exposed to it and I always
just enjoyed the feelings that you got
and watching stories play out and the
imagination of it and then I think
getting involved in kind of role playing
games and that kind of stuff was a
continuation of that you know how much I
loved assault in cellblock 99 I loved I
am anxiously awaiting seeing dragged
across concrete please tell me when
people can see I'm not sure I it's a
cool movie we went to
beyond fest with it the movie played at
the Venice Film Festival as well as all
ours my favorite he's such a tremendous
storyteller and it's cool it's it's a
different kind of movie he does his own
sort of a unique story with this as it's
different from kind of you know I think
in the same palette but different than
bone tomahawk which I which I loved and
it's cool he does all the original music
for it again composed all of the
original music I believe the OJS are
back performing with him so there's a
lot of cool stuff in it and Mel's
terrific in the film
yeah I heard Mel connect yes very much
so he's okay yeah he's tremendous right
exactly so there's basically there's no
word in terms of like a release date I
don't know I know Lionsgate has it the
movie in classic Zoller form the movie
is long and Zoller likes it that way so
he's you know he kind of makes these
movies and I think it's great but he
kind of makes these movies and sort of
locks them to his own taste you know
same with cell block there's no real
testing or anything saying with bone
tomahawk so it's all are kind of
intended to make a movie like this and
it's exactly what he made I seriously
cannot wait to see it especially with
how awesome Cell Block 99 is if you
don't mind I just have a few fun ones
please okay here we go by the way thank
you for being so indulgent we really
appreciate it would you rather see your
movie before its festival premiere or go
into the premiere screening blind gosh I
guess either ways fine I guess I you
kind of watch it and the first time
you're seeing it I'm not as precious
with that maybe because I've been
through the editing room process on the
other side as well you'd kind of know
what that experience is like so I kind
of like seeing things with an audience
though so I enjoyed watching something
with other people they're responding I
like that that experience so I would be
fine either way
I got it I'm gonna rewind a second I was
at the TIFF premiere of cell block 99
and I remember I was sitting I think a
row or two behind you and you and you
were having so much fun watching and the
crowd was going bananas and I just
remember seeing you just looked like you
were having a blast well it's always
interesting because there was people you
know cheering at parts that I didn't
expect and that's what's so fun when you
see with an audience that's what it
takes on a life of its own and you know
that's the thing I think with films and
having that experience is sometimes
people will inform you
about sense of humor or what scary or
ideas you know you sort of take on kind
of a group consciousness so if that was
fun because it was like you know there
you're breaking people's arms or you're
doing things to prison guards and like
and these people were really rooting for
Bradley and I just found that to be kind
of like oh that's interesting
it was awesome yeah would you rather
would you rather walk around Sundance
with no gloves or wet boots no gloves
would be preferable
would you rather meet a new collaborator
at a festival or reconnect with someone
you've worked with before interesting
both could be exciting probably probably
a new collaboration I have a lot of
great old collaborations that I continue
with and I hope those continue but it's
always exciting to meet someone new and
and get inspired by some new ideas would
you rather do festival interviews with a
co-star that talks too much or not
enough boy that's a great question Thank
You Barry you can answer that question
probably better than anybody
I would assume probably talks too much
as preferable but I can't say it as an
absolute now in your experience in
interviewing you probably notice a lot
of times where people are sitting
together making it like things are
fantastic but you could probably tell
there's some trouble at the dinner table
with these two right I have noticed that
it's also you know something it's how do
you navigate that uh each listen the
fact is if you're doing an interview
like this where it's extended it doesn't
matter when you're doing a four-minute
interview at the four seasons or
whatever and they're in a room and
there's four people and you have four
minutes I mean not to curse but you're
[ __ ] because if one person just talks
for two minutes which is I'll give you a
great story please I saw I interviewed
for age of Ultron James Spader and I
think Paul Bettany and I asked like a
harmless question like what's the worst
job you've had and James Spader who I
loved gave a four minute answer right
and then they're like you're wrapped and
I'm like I have not asked about the
movie and they're like oh you can ask
one more thing but it was one of these
things where I couldn't believe James
just kept talking continue with the
second question no no no he who put a
nickel in James that day right it was
just four minutes on his worst job and
it was like listening have you seen the
blacklist yes okay it was like
reddington just it being James Spader
and him tell acting like Reddington just
going on and I'm like Paul did Paul seem
happy by this he he seemed like I don't
think he was frustrated right but it was
one of these like I think he was smiling
a little bit like this is just James
yeah but it was it's very difficult
because yes I can't interrupt him right
I'm you're giving what's called kind of
a first question to kind of break the
ice yeah it was a it was a nice break a
little background flavor yes now you're
gonna get to the meat which is tell me
about your point of view on whether it
was a performance or the movie how it
came together and guess what everyone
got full on the appetizers it was
bananas
but there's nothing you can do nothing
you can do nothing nothing you can uh
would you rather would you rather mess
up every take yourself or have someone
mess up your best take interesting
would you rather mess up every I guess I
would rather have someone mess up my
best take because I would like to feel
always that I'm prepared and ready to go
and what you described mess up to me
might mean something different because I
think it's really about listening and
reacting and you don't necessarily know
always where it's going to go so
sometimes what appears to be a mess-up
can be a great thing I'm assuming if you
forget lines or stumble and and
depending on the director of the film
that can actually turn out to be okay
too but I do appreciate it and I guess I
would as much as you don't like someone
kind of doing that but I'd rather feel
that that I was on par versus versus the
one kind of bringing everybody down I
totally get it
would you out would you rather have to
cry or laugh in a scene well I guess
they're similar that you want to find a
way in that feels like it's happening
you know truthfully both can dry up so
you want to be prepared to kind of be
ready and then have something spark you
and and kind of be ready to go in as as
that goes on in either case it can start
to dry up and then you have to try to
find new things and both can be tiring
but as
as I try to think about it out loud I
guess I would rather well I guess I'd
rather laugh because that's a more fun
day sure right then you're kind of in a
lighter mood and you can kind of joke
around and be put yourself in a good
place because that kind of works but
with what you're stepping into and the
crying you know you're trying not to cry
but you have to get yourself kind of in
a headspace that's sometimes not you
don't not a great place to live in can
you cry on command or I don't know if I
do it on command but but I don't I mean
that can you bring it like if you have
to it's a strange thing I don't even you
don't even analyze it's like you kind of
build up everyone has their different
techniques for how they do it right so
yes I can I feel very confident to go
into a scene and emotionally be
available depending on what it calls for
sure I could ask you a million other
things but you have to do what's called
other interviews and yes other things
yes I'm just gonna say because I messed
up at the beginning a huge thank you to
Kia telluride they're our sponsor and
they're the only reason I get to be at
Sundance and my Collider is here so huge
thank you to Kia Telluride
which is right here I'm just giving them
a nice plug because you know you have a
new car coming out in September no a
little Range Rover Range Rover esque yes
but seriously thanks but more
importantly thank you thank you my
friend always great appreciated thank
you I think people are gonna really love
it I appreciate that
um thanks that's a great day yep we'll
see you soon
you